good good time so far have you been able
to walk around the convention floor
something you have yesterday um but it
was really busy yeah did you pick up
anything cool I got my sister some toy
I can't and then I did a book signing
with Alex Brackett awesome well of
course yeah this is based off of a
series of novels that has a big fan
following let's talk about the premise
of the movie yeah sure so the darkest
minds is about a world where most
children have been killed by this
mysterious disease and those that are
left have developed spooky powers of
mind control telekinesis advanced
intelligence fire electricity and fire
there is six novels right I believe the
six ones coming out yeah Wow Wow
so I mean I know it's a little early you
gotta wait for like box-office red tape
whatever but is there a plan to just do
kind of like a series of these films
make this what happened yeah well so
much pretend to inside of the universe
of film as well when it expands like
constantly and it's amazing so it would
be nice to yeah to keep it going
you guys seem to like each other so
that's good these characters are very
beloved can you guys kind of go around
say who you're playing and maybe the
biggest difference from the novels you
start down here I play a catechol limb
Stewart and he is blue which means he's
telekinetic and we meet him as he right
I always go to like tell the story then
I realize I'm white he's family
leave this group into like a safer Haven
and my character's name is Xue and she's
a gold which means she has the power of
electricity she doesn't exactly know how
to use her powers quite yet because
she's she's the youngest of the four and
so she like you she's very protective so
she uses her powers most of the time to
just like if she feels that these three
these three are in danger then she'll
use her powers and they kind of go out
of control sometimes but she just does
it for good she's trying to hone it it
yeah I played chubs the enhanced
intelligence is my cover and basically
I'm able to in turn speak different
languages I'll be able to understand
different languages and kinda like in a
3d type of way which they do in CGI
parts I'm able to like see math problems
or you know solve equations or hear
radio frequency you know so smart guy
smart guy like that math meme come to
life I play Ruby daily she's classified
as an orange and that means that she's a
power of mind control so she can mess
people's thoughts she can make them do
things
she can see people's memory she can
manipulate their memories she can share
her memories and in terms of her story
arc think she's in the process of
finding out how to be our most powerful
so like I mentioned you know this these
novels have a huge fan following already
so have you guys been able to kind of
interact with these these fans yet I
mean we are alive so people I think
automatically kind of try to make
comparisons so people say hey I'm an
Hunger Games what do you say to those
comparisons and how is this different I
think they're really wildly different I
mean this is set in a world that's not
too distant from ours so it's not too
far in the future I mean it's a stoking
in tone but if anything it's kind of
reflective of what's happening
and then in terms of our powers it's I
think it's based a little more and like
elements of sci-fi or thriller and that
like we're not these epic superheroes
we're actually just kids with this
strange ability that we've gathered and
so we're trying to figure out how to use
it yeah
a little off topic but I was at this
vampire weekend concert there first one
in four years and imagine my surprise
it's lovely and violinist comes out and
sings with them and it's you that was
yeah that was amazing I mean and then I
kind of went that because you have such
an amazing voice and I was looking at
your kind of a history of music but is
there a plan to maybe continue kind of
doing your own thing maybe going yet um
yeah I've been learning how to produce
something working my own feats and
tracks and stuff and getting in the
studio a bit so yeah I definitely want
to cobble together an EP I think it's
just happening right now testing
different things out and dipping my toes
yeah oh so funny because like you came
out I was like I mean I know her yes it
was great and also Maleficent too over
here what bat I mean that is such an
incredible cast what is it like being on
that set yeah it's mad it's pretty fun
it's like that strange thing I've been
I've been like horse riding and sword
fighting and I feel like I'm fulfilling
every night childhood dream I ever had
just so excited and obviously working
with them guys is amazing like
constantly learning yeah well speaking
of incredible cast I mean this this film
as well you've got one only Christy
you've got Mandy Moore I mean we're you
guys fans up this is us game thrones i
use Mandy's
amazing actor and I know that three
little kids like the younger version of
the adults so I mean I haven't watched
the show that much
I just know them so you could say I'm a
fan and a friend fan in front I'm a
massive fan of Game of Thrones and I got
to do we got a few scenes with Gwendolen
yeah rocks the coolest lady ever who was
she played was she playing in the movie
lady Jane Jane
she's a bounty hunter okay yeah that's
like very appropriate for her yeah their
answer that well yeah before we sign off
I mean we are alive with the fans I need
anything you guys want to say go see
them please you know go ahead and you
know
thank you guys so much for watching
we're gonna get that photo booth take
some photos have some fun and happy
comic-con
[Music]